the dawn of the Cold War this talk from
the Woodrow Wilson Center in Washington
DC is an hour ten minutes as many of you
know the cold winter national history
project has for the last decade in fact
almost 15 years by now made an effort to
obtain collect translate and publish new
evidence new archival documents from the
former communist world archives make
them accessible the raw materials of
history to historians journalists and
anybody interested in Cold War history
around the globe our major publication
is the cold winter national history
project bulletins available outside as
well if you're interested there are no
longer com please just let me know and
i'll be happy to put you in our mailing
list occasionally we also host seminars
here washington on new important books
on Cold War history and it's such a book
that will be discussing today read spies
in America stolen secrets and the dawn
of the Cold War by Katherine Sibley to
my very left here it's them to my
immediate left here it's a great
pleasure to have dr. Sibley with us you
have longer biographical information in
front of you so I'll keep it very short
dr. Sibley is associate professor and
chair of the history department at st.
Joseph's University in Philadelphia and
North American book review editor for
the renowned journal intelligence and
national security she received her PhD
from the University of California Santa
Barbara and has published widely this is
her third book her first book concerned
us-russian relations that US Russia
economic relations focused on the 1930s
loans and legitimacy devolution
servet American relations 1919 to 1933
she later on followed this with a
collection and document anthology the
Cold War published in 1998 and has now
produced the book she will present today
red spies in America let me turn it over
to Catherine said it's wonderful to have
you here and we look forward to your
presentation about half an hour after
which i'll introduce our distinguished
commentator dr. Haines and then we'll
turn it over to you for questions
commentary and later on some cheese and
beverages outside for reception
Catherine thank you so much Christian
it's such a pleasure to be here I
remember having you at st. Joe's a few
years back and that was also a pleasure
so it's wonderful to be here and I'm so
thrilled to see you all thank you so
much for coming and I'm really looking
forward to talking to you a little bit
today about my recent book read spies in
America it was during World War Two as
FBI director I don't think I have to
introduce it right you all know who this
is j edgar Hoover well knew that
American Communist made their deepest
inroads upon our national life a
suspicious source you say hmm well at
this point the director knew what he was
talking about he did some other times to
these inroads of course included
espionage and the discovery this would
deeply preoccupy Hoover and his minions
during the war years it was Moscow's
illicit wartime intelligence gathering
which centered on American military
industry that first convinced the FBI
and other agencies of the need for more
vigilant approach to Russia during World
War two even as the two powers work
closely together along with the British
three powers I should give them credit
to infighting first the Nazi menace and
then Japanese militarism but for most
scholars and most of the general public
however the cold war remains the moment
when Americans first seized upon the
issue of communist espionage and how
remember doing this thank you so most
recall the Cold War is the beginning of
that moment and when the government used
the specter of a threatening Soviet
Union to create the present-day American
domestic security state and
counterintelligence system a system now
burgeoning by the way once again in the
wake of sep tember 11th as I don't need
to tell you with such legislative
measures as the USA patriot act it was
in the early Cold War as historian Alan
shredder writes the Espionage became
central to the popular perception that
communists in danger of the United
States her assessment is widely shared
World War two by contrast has often
appeared to be the Golden Age of
soviet-american relations and if you're
wondering what's going on here this sort
of a i think a young cross-border fret
fraternizing dance going on and you can
see Americans are being welcomed by
Soviets George F Kenan recalled that in
1943 the Soviet Union was hardly
regarded by our top people in the
government as an enemy great masses of
American materials were being prepared
for shipment to the Soviet Union many of
them I assume involving the transmission
of Official Secrets well that's true
lachlan curry sorry I don't have a
better slide of him an aide to FDR
during the war declared that quote we
were all united the atmosphere of
suspicion and caution only arose after i
left the government in 1945 indeed a
wholly different atmosphere then
prevailed as Lloyd Garrison Council to J
robert Oppenheimer contended in 1954
quote the whole attitude toward Russia
toward persons who were sympathetic with
Russia everything was different from
what obtains today he reckoned in the
midst of his clients security hearings
in 1954 but it was not entirely so
different instead the government's
developing wartime outlook embraced a
new set of assumptions about the danger
of the Soviet Union close to the United
States an understanding indeed that
would influence American political
culture throughout the Cold War as late
as the Carter Administration with j
edgar Hoover five years in his grave his
former agency maintained the name of
wartime spy Jolla bar in its
index and here his bar with his
girlfriend Vivian Glassman Steve Austin
here yes he's writing a new book about
jello bar so look forward to that coming
out the end of the year I think good and
Louise and Alfred Saran close friends a
bar here bar had been been missing this
is in the 1970s we're missing for almost
30 years but there was an order at
customs to interdict him if you were to
return to America s FBI officials
alleged quote because of his previous
work on behalf of the Soviets it is
believed he has the willingness and
capability to engage in espionage indeed
this wartime outlook had long-lasting
reverberations in popular culture as
well encompass Singh the species of
Soviet mole who is prominent Cold War
spy fiction like that of John Luke are a
haunting the dark and vulnerable
interstices of Western democracies
political and military industrial
complex in the eyes of American counter
intelligence officials this mole had
already assumed recognizable shape and
less ambiguity in World War two inside
the FBI and US military intelligence a
small but active coterie of these men
recognized the growing infiltration of
Soviet spies well before the Cold War
and made limited but nevertheless
pioneering efforts to stop them it is
their work that is the heart of my book
and by the way don't take these pictures
literally just after all it's all secret
right so I just have to give you some
portrayal of what it might have looked
like I would now like to give you a
brief overview of the books argument and
scope and then highlight its contents
with some examples of Soviet spies were
important to my story Soviet
intelligence gained great deal material
from deductive networks of American
agents in manufacturing firms and the US
military in World War two such as Jacob
goalless and Gregory silver master who
had various sources in the Pentagon and
in war industry Julius Rosenberg who had
a group of electrical engineers and
defense plants and contacts in the
atomic project Harry gold and I
understand someone is also writing a
book about Harry gold here this is lots
of new stuff to look forward to his his
work in the chemical industry and then
unfortunately don't have a better
picture Igor Gouzenko is revealed ring
of radar and nuclear specialists in
Canada
of course the large number of sources in
the manhattan project itself very few of
these agents or sources were discovered
at the time of course the FBI remained
largely unaware and other agencies as
well did of the extent that the
government and industry had been
penetrated by Soviet espionage
nevertheless those who were identified
contributed to the emergence of a
pervasive anti-soviet outlook in the
counter intelligence community well
before the Cold War this evidence of
industrial and military spying drew
American officials to the conclusion the
Soviet Union and its agents were
significant and growing threat to a
vulnerable United States red spies in
America begins in the 1930s with an
examination of some of the earliest
Soviet military espionage efforts here
paying close attention to Washington's
contemporary but rather limited
conception of a Soviet threat in that
era as well as the connections between
such early spy activities and later
espionage episodes in 1933 diplomatic
ties everybody know who this is great
Philadelphian or perhaps not so great
William bullet and the gloves are
interesting because he didn't like the
Soviets after a while he was our first
ambassador there and so probably gloves
or maybe 10 foot pole would have been
the way he would have liked to have
handled them wasn't a very effective
ambassador nevertheless we did open
relations with them 1933 as you may know
and his work assisted in furthering this
opening assisted in furthering Moscow's
access to American secrets allowing
scores of Soviet inspectors to visit
American plants offering regular
opportunities for intelligence gathering
and facilitating the entry of numerous
legal and illegal agents these agents
including whittaker chambers and many
others would groom some of Moscow's most
devoted servants in the years thereafter
during an era when public sentiment kept
counterintelligence agents on a short
leash based on a popular antipathy to
manifestations of official investigate
or e power yes indeed we did have that
history American officials could pay
little attention to these activities but
in the years between the nazi-soviet
pact and the start of World War Two
1939-1945 it--and awareness and
suspicions about foreign threats and FBI
agents and other military officials took
a closer look at the practices of Soviet
agents even as authorities launched
investigation
which led to the arrest of such
notorious pies as gig over Kim Ian and
the aforementioned Jacob goals goalless
is espionage show ever went largely
unnoticed instead it was his position as
an unregistered foreign agent that drew
official attention by then the
international situation created in a
quote emergency at home that augmented
the FBI's domestic responsibilities and
budgets as raid that vitus has written
about and will write more about I trust
in an unprecedented fashion one result
was the bureau's extensive investigation
of the am tour agency a Russian trading
agency here I just have a picture from
Russia but it was in New York which
helped to convince agents of a yet only
Merkel e imagined Russian espionage
system at the dawn of World War two
during the War Soviet military
industrial espionage expanded greatly
not surprisingly it was a period of
extensive Soviet American military
cooperation and the work of such spies
as Abraham bronfman alfred slack the
silver master group the Rosenbergs and
others i've mentioned demonstrated the
extent of soviet penetration in american
defense plants as well as the depths
Moscow's agents reached in the secret
drawers of the Pentagon and its military
industrial planners with a few notable
exceptions like the efforts of Andhra
Shevchenko in the aircraft industry
which led to a successful
counterespionage sting operation this
work went on without the faintest
knowledge almost all of it of American
counterintelligence ages atomic
espionage by contrast did draw and was
soon much more blatant to ignore drew
the attention of these agents in March
1943 FBI surveillance uncovered a
meeting in which Berkeley radiation
laboratory scientist Joseph wonder
Weinberg who was seen in this picture
got these pictures from McGregor
conceived out Brotherhood of the bombs
many of you may have read a Weinberg is
here on the far on your far left and
he's next to a Giovanni Rossi low
minutes these are all scientists at the
California radiation laboratory in
Berkeley and the other two men are max
bomb and David Friedman so the only
person I'm talking about right now is
Weinberg but there's the picture
Weinberg shared information with
California cognis leader Steve Nelson
here in his army uniform from the
Civil War he was active in California
during the early 40s just two weeks
later after they had the FBI had
recorded this conversation between
Weinberg the scientist and Nelson the
communist spy agents recorded a
representative the NKVD by the name of
Vaseline Rubin meeting with Nelson quote
and paying him for placing Communist
Party members and common tern agents in
industrial in industries engaged in
secret war production so that the
information could be obtained for
transmittal to the Soviet Union this was
apparently the first time that the FBI
had recorded a party official being paid
for providing classified technical
information on the bomb to Russian
intelligence agents understanding of the
threat posed by the Soviet Union
expanded accordingly the issue only
became more vexing when manhattan
project leader J robert Oppenheimer here
seen with that general groves told
military officials a rather convoluted
story about members of his staff haven't
been contacted by Soviet agents right
around the same time in 1943 FBI at the
same time or shortly thereafter FBI
surveillance of longtime Soviet agent
Arthur Adams uncovered his meetings with
Clarence iski a chemist at the Manhattan
projects Chicago metallurgical
laboratory where the plutonium pile was
under development a search of adams
hotel room in September 1944 indicated
that he had been gathering materials on
the atomic bomb from his key the
defection of Igor Gouzenko shortly
thereafter the cipher clerk at the
Soviet embassy in Toronto revealed an
even more alarming espionage operation a
year later and Harris Nikolai's a boat
in the military attache and ahead of the
ring I'm sorry oh oh yes sorry about
that oh thank you correct that thank you
very much guzheng ko's allegations we
don't want to mix up our Canadian cities
it's bad enough how was you know phobic
we are here right crews thank those
allegations of Soviet spying on Canadian
and American nuclear and radar research
substantiated by a hundred and nine
documents he had secreted out of the
embassy help to consolidate a highly
suspicious outlook that American
officials now directed to the Soviets
and their allies in the United States
though Hoover and his colleagues in
Counter Intelligence had long been
convinced of the dangers of Soviet
spying and subversion by the wars and
other agencies like the State Department
and here you have secretary state so
genius giving us commendation to a man
who probably needs no introduction in
this audience Alger Hiss had been less
unified in their views about the threat
of the Soviet issue the new post-war
atmosphere however allow the FBI's
perspective to gain a much wider
following in the US government thus
assuring in the broad anti-communist
consensus of the post-war years the
steepening distrusted obvious
implications for the developing Cold War
assuring a new loyalty programs export
controls heightened security and new
investigations it was during the Cold
War as well that the first revelations
from the venona decrypts became
available which provided clues to
infamous wartime spies and many of you I
think are aware of these Soviet cables
that were Declassified in 1996 and led
agents in the United States
counterintelligence community to such
spies as Judith Kaplan william pearl and
Klaus Fuchs by then of course by the
late 40s when many of these people had
been named elizabeth bentley here with L
William Remington one of the people she
named her famous defection in 1945 had
thrown Soviet espionage operations from
the war to complete disarray her
revelations however did help to
consolidate the Cold War's Harding
reaction to world war 2 espionage is
reflected in the trials of Remington and
the relentless pursuit of Steve Nelson
after the war the Rosenberg case and a
number of other examples including the
hearings of Oppenheimer only in the
post-war era as these defections became
known about and as the code cracking
developed in the Venona project only
then did authorities begin to approach
an understanding of the full picture and
as John is just inform we've only
recently now discovered the name of yet
another spy who has been unknown until
the present moment so it continues right
these discoveries my book concludes then
with a brief survey of Soviet and
Russian espionage World War 2 to the
present as it confirms unlike wartime
spying since recent espionage had been
much more motivated by cash than by
communism moreover several the recent
spies like John Walker Aldrich Ames
robert hansen offered their services
much longer and probably did far more
damage
than these wartime predecessors and of
course justice in the war years
political realities often der feared or
assisted the capture of these spies
global they taught be an example of when
it was a little bit touchy to go after
spies perhaps it's not surprising then
that the largest number of spies was
captured in the post-war era in 1985
during the Reagan administration the
so-called year of the spy many grew
convinced that Soviet agents were even
more active than than they had ever been
but actually the high number of arrests
could be probably tied to some an
earlier President Jimmy Carter because
during his period a number of laws were
enacted that made it easier to go after
spies measures which of course are being
used today to investigate terrorists and
others nevertheless despite the sheer
volume material passed on by these more
recent spies it was the earlier wartime
military industrial agents who practiced
such techniques that have established a
template for Soviet later Russian
intelligence that continues to this very
day so my book then looks most closely
at wartime espionage and the American
response to it limited attention in
scholarship has been devoted to this
issue I would suggest especially
communist espionage in military industry
or the way in which this particular
issue and our government's reaction to
have created a precedent for later
investigations and surveillance etc in
the Cold War just as an example of this
in an analysis of the 1954 hearings of
Oppenheimer historian Barton Bernstein
noted that quote since 1947
Oppenheimer's FBI file had swelled from
frequent wiretaps some physical
surveillance occasional charges of
disloyalty etc but many of these
practices had been expand against
Oppenheimer since nineteen forty one
because of his suspected communist
leanings but some historians have
suggested that wartime the wartime
Alliance actually diminished this kind
of surveillance another example is Steve
Nelson here with his lawyer Emmanuel
block in late 1940s the Communist Party
leader who I mentioned earlier whose
home was already under surveillance as
early as 1942 um this is not his home by
the way this is the California radiation
laboratory that I mentioned you at
Berkeley where scientists were coming to
coming from to meet with Nelson and give
him information one of the first ones
who came was a fellow you saw a picture
of earlier Giovanni Rossi luminance in
October 1942 now outside or nearby was
the FBI informant listening in who
didn't seem to understand too much of
what was being said because of course
it's a secret project and what did the
FBI know about this yet but they were
quite concerned about some of the things
that were being discussed nevertheless
one of the things that Nelson said to
luminous was that this was even more
important than party work it's important
he said for the party to have knowledge
of these discoveries that you were doing
at the radiation laboratory moreover now
luminance was told you are considered an
undercover member of the party you
should quiet your party activity behaved
too sweetly stay away from alcohol ok so
uninformed about this important project
nevertheless the FBI had been watching
Nelson since nineteen forty the Office
of Naval Intelligence had been not
watching him even earlier since nineteen
thirty-nine they had been listening to
him in party meetings etc in May 1941
FBI Special Agent njl Piper recommended
that Nelson be considered for quote
custodial detention at the u.s. entered
a national emergency and Hoover agreed
with that he called for telephone
surveillance on Nelson in light of its
position in the party in San Francisco
as well as particular interest in
matters pertinent to national defense
this request was only granted early
nineteen forty two and that's why they
were able to take luminous but the
nevertheless despite this action the
investigation developed only slowly kind
of reflecting the bureau's slow
appreciation and understanding of Soviet
espionage in this era meanwhile the FBI
was watching Oppenheimer more closely
looking for his communist connections
the bureau kept track of his
conversations magazine subscriptions
activities lovers etc and any of you out
there who were communists experts will
know that this is this is from actually
at 92 1920s it's not a contemporary
document with our conversation but I
want to give you a flavor of some of the
magazines they might have thought he was
reading we now know that he was most
certainly a member bureau and military
intelligence officers watched not only
him but his wife his brother and his
former girlfriend all of whom had ties
to the party their suspicions no doubt
only deepened
when they discovered that his wife Kitty
had been married to Steve Nelson's old
friend Joe dalit a fellow veteran of the
Spanish Civil War Oppenheimer's party
membership couldn't be proved during the
war but this hardly stop lieutenant
colonel Baris pass who headed the
military intelligence arm of the
Manhattan projects investigate
investigative wing from asserting that
oppenheimer quote is not to be fully
trusted and his loyalty to the nation is
divided pash believe that Oppenheimer
was providing material to persons quote
who may be furnished get to the
communist party for transmission to the
USSR and recommended he be replaced of
course he was not replaced because
general Leslie our groves made the point
that the atomic project you know would
not happen without his help so that was
the end of the effort to get rid of
Oppenheimer and we can discuss this
after but I haven't died yet to be
convinced at Oppenheimer was a spy um
party member yes but not as fine people
were worried though the FBI meanwhile
could not be mollified about that
Oppenheimer despite their investigation
they had evidence that his connections
to the party were actually loosening but
they would not they would not be calm
about this because they knew that his
connections with steve nelson were um if
anything you know considered to be
substantial although they weren't
necessarily in a tape 1943 discussion
with Weinberg mentioned before Joseph
Weinberg the radiation laboratory
scientist Nelson told Weinberg that
while he had talked to Oppenheimer about
the project you not pressed him since
quote I didn't want to put him in on a
friendly position I didn't want to put
him on a spot you know Nelson
acknowledged that he and the party made
the physicist uncomfortable even jittery
Weinberg complained that as for himself
Oppenheimer had quote deliberately kept
him from the project both men agreed
that Oppenheimer was just not a Marxist
and while he would like to be on the
right track he was being pushed away by
his wife who was influencing him in the
wrong direction Pratt she was ambitious
for his career anyway Nelson and
wineries track however definitely
included espionage as a bureau learned
on the night of March 29th 1943 the
Congress needed was overheard securing
information on the nuclear experiments
as the FBI put it from Weinberg Weinberg
told Nelson chiefly about the process
connected with a calutron and this is
to the lair picture I don't think it was
as far developed in 1943 this was a
separator of isotopes that could enrich
uranium and he was nervous to tell this
but Nelson Preston and so he did so most
of the material the bureau was hearing
from this conversation was
unintelligible to them they were not
technically that adept at some of these
more arcane aspects of nuclear research
however they were quite adept at seeing
that soon after his meeting with
Weinberg Nelson was seen passing
materials to a Soviet vice consul in San
Francisco known as Peter Petrovitch
Ivanov and Ivan off mean I was working
other avenues he had also contacted a
chemist called George CL tintin who was
at a nearby oil company was known to be
sympathetic to the party and told him
this is Ivan off the soviet
representative telling l Tintin the
Russians needs her information and for
political reasons there were no
authorized channels through which they
could obtain such Elton to knew that
there was a friend of Oppenheimer's who
perhaps would help him this was
professor of French at Berkeley hakan
chevaliers close friend of Oppenheimer L
Tintin pressed Chevalier to quote find
out what was being done at the radiation
laboratory particularly information
regarding the highly destructive weapon
which was being developed in chevaliers
later telling of the story the whole
suggestion was pretty posterous and
often harvey are fine to hear of it yet
he nevertheless decided to tell quote
his intimate and steadfast friend
Oppenheimer the physicists the business
is flatly slammed these entreaties as
treason but he did not tell Oppenheimer
did not tell army security about them
for another six months and the story he
told was then largely fabricated but so
was it turned out with chevaliers
version of events despite such miss and
disinformation along with numerous miss
clues about the abundance of Soviet
espionage in world war two was later
revealed by detect defectors venona and
newly open Soviet sources the
discoveries by the FBI and other counter
intelligence officials I would argue
were nevertheless significant and
because of these earlier miss told
stories in part it's later reaction in
that of other security agencies was only
more bitter in regard to the individuals
involved as Oppenheimer would
unfortunately discover in contrast then
to officials obliviousness in the 1930s
here they are looking for fingerprints
nothing wrong with that of course but
this was a chief operation of the FBI in
the nineteen thirty
a significant chunk of its time this
wartime realization galvanized
counterintelligence agents to action
including new espionage investigations
Sri Dasha in this anti-soviet consensus
that we are all familiar with from the
Cold War it may have been the case that
the FBI had no quote formal
counterintelligence program is aiding
peak who's here in our audience contents
and thus no systematic way to root out
spies and debrief defectors still FBI
surveillance did force out such Soviet
representatives in the war as Semyon
Semyonovich contact among others Gregory
Heifetz seen here on your right leaving
the infamous Bernstein's fish grotto in
San Francisco see me after if you want
more details maybe we still around I
don't know good food probably vassilisa
Reuben others all these people were
oppressed by the FBI indirectly or
directly to return to Russia US
officials effectively stymied such spies
as well as Clarence iski and and Ray
shevchenko moreover their monitoring of
Nelson even though it never led to
actually any case effective case against
him and Arthur Adams and others
effectively probably hindered them from
additional espionage as well now
certainly the government as I've alluded
to had great difficulty in effectively
prosecuting spies during the war
afterward evidence like the venona
materials the wiretaps were not
acceptable in court even if you had this
man arguing for you though the venona
materials and revelations of such former
spies is Bentley among other sources
have more recently been verified in
numerous Russian and American
collections thanks to the work of John
Harvey claire and others as shredder
emphasizes Ellen strecker such
allegations could not be proven at the
time indeed the lack of evidence
sufficient to meet the high thresholds
of American criminal justice system
contribute to a vitriolic debate in this
country with anti-communist like Joseph
McCarthy charging the government had
ignored a clear menace as skeptical
academics continue to see the lack of
prosecutor orak success as evidence that
espionage allegations like Bentley's
were unreliable and probably little
spine had occurred at all in the years
since as scholars like Richard powers
have pointed out the government self
hardly cleared matters it's zealous
secrecy about Celine espionage venona as
we've met
and remain secret until the mid-90s FBI
files still emerged with many redactions
all of us helped to enshrine a scholarly
consensus that satisfying largely did
not exist Morris is Herman recently told
me scholar of American communism that in
his interviews with Steve Nelson in the
1970s and 1980s Nelson died in nineteen
ninety the subject of atomic espionage
did not even come up because Nelson of
course had dismissed the idea in his
1981 biography that Communist Party
members would spy I mean how silly would
that be of course they wouldn't well now
we know they did some anyway now of
course with venona open and some
scholars having obtained limited access
to selected KGB files the subject has
enjoyed a huge outpouring of scholarly
analyses and some not so scholarly as a
result in contrast long-held academic
perspective that few of any American
communists engaged in spying numerous
scholars now argued Soviet espionage
actively dwarfed not only what many
scholars had traditionally understood
but and some of course traditionalists
did always think it did exist but also
what many US officials thought at the
time as noted in addition to the
significant cases which first alerted
Soviet American agents I'm sorry to
Soviet espionage that I discuss in the
book there were of course many many
examples that were undetected by Hoover
I promise you that's the nastiest
picture I have of him okay other than
that you don't there's gonna be nothing
else that's going to reflect anything
further on Hoover he was focused focused
on this task but nevertheless he missed
a lot um any what was he going to do the
Soviets were quite secret about this and
it was difficult American officials only
dimly understood the scope of this
espionage effort their countermeasures
were on the whole ineffective
nevertheless they weren't entirely
ineffective as I've noted and Soviet
intelligence agents could only ignore us
counter espionage activities even
halting ones only at their peril futile
as they might be such efforts remained
an ever-present threat as shown in the
case of Gregory silver master one of
Elizabeth Bentley's main sources he was
the government as economist who first
drew the attention of investigators in
1942 when he took a job at the bureau of
economic warfare he had been in the
government before this but this was
considered to be a sensitive agency and
his politics were of some concern the
Navy the War Department objected
the house on American Activities
Committee had him on a list as well as
his wife 100 suspected government
employees or other otherwise related to
the Communist Party yet there was no no
way that investigators could turn up
anything enough to cost him his job and
he remained on the payroll the federal
government till 1945 turning over
enormous amounts of information to the
Russians from his sources in the
Pentagon for instance he provided
statistics on a full range of american
war production radar submarines bombers
all kinds of things and his superiors
were concerned about this in the soviet
union they consoled themselves however
by remarking they're concerned that you
know the FBI was aware of him if they
have not dismissed him from his present
work it means that there is no concrete
information about his work for us but
only suspicions about his party
membership the US government would let
silver master slip away but Moscow still
could not relax as one agent noted there
is no guarantee one Soviet agent that as
a result of some accident materials he
may have at his place will not fall into
the hands of the FBI that would mean
that our sources would be compromised as
the war continued US security officials
grew more sophisticated in their
initiatives more successful Julius
Rosenberg handler Alexander feckless saw
for instance argued that in 1944 quote
the spectacular tightening of FBI
surveillance had sent leading
intelligence agents Semyon Semyonovich
to Moscow the FBI force had begun
deploying newly authorized techniques
such as wiretapping as we've mentioned
first authorized by FDR in 1940s
informants number of other things that
they had long used these had helped
launch various investigations of
Communists such as the communist
infiltration of the radiation
laboratories at Berkeley the so-called
simrad and the calm rap Comintern
apparatus pro both launched in the war
years they maintained a security index
of so-called dangerous officials even
though the Attorney General during the
war one of the Attorney General's anyway
Francis Biddle called this unpractical
unwise and dangerous to have such a list
the FBI had one and eventually
identified a million people with
communist front associations these the
sheer number was not a very useful
reflection of real communist activity
because of course the number in the
party was less than a hundred thousand
but just I think shows you the tenor of
the agency's approach to this issue so
FDR of course oh sorry
picture of the radiation laboratory
there and here is FDR in a lighter
moment and he of course was sympathetic
to the FDA to the FBI's role here he
often would go around the Attorney
General because he wanted the
information they could provide him about
suspicious elements perhaps not always
communist so much but people who might
be opposed to the war and other kinds of
things now speaking of FDR we know that
he was not as active in the cause of
Soviet espionage as he might have been
we I think many of you familiar with the
reports he got about Whittaker Chambers
in 1939 and how little was done about
that certainly with the war developing
after 1939 we've being allies of the
Soviet Union these were certainly
constraints on what Hoover could do
about pursuing Soviet spies nevertheless
the FBI did not cease to make many
efforts to document Soviet espionage
practices it was a frustrating
experience and it did lead the end of
the war for the FBI to push its agenda
and its emphasis on Soviet espionage at
top volume when of course there was a
more receptive opening for it the
American response to Soviet spies that
during the war years was generally
unsuccessful if measured by the amount
of spies caught nevertheless they expand
an understanding of Soviet spine that
emerged in this period led the
government to adopt a new approach in
us-soviet relations an approach that
aggressively employed counter
intelligence techniques and led to an
enlarged American security system among
its legacies would be an expanded house
on American Activities Committee loyalty
oaths an enormous powerful military
industrial security complex that of
course continues to grow today by 1959
already such methods had shrunk
Communist Party membership to a few
thousand a significant percentage of
whom were FBI agents as events in the
1950s and after showed though an
anti-soviet outlook had quickly become
official orthodoxy in the Cold War
embracing not only the counter
intelligence community but the public's
elected representatives the discovery of
Soviet spies in the Warriors had sparked
the charged atmosphere of post-war
America and left a legacy of suspicion
that would continue for decades thank
you so much
thank you very much Katie as many of you
know the field of espionage of
intelligence history is an extremely
controversial 11 it's very much
politically charged due in part to the
still fragmentary evidence fragmentary
record that exists and so it's a true
pleasure to have one of the finest
historians in the field surveys
commentator today dr. john earl Haines
is the 20th century political historian
with the manuscript division of the
Library of Congress that actually gives
your description of the state day job
but it hides the fact that he's one of
the leading intelligence historians of
our day has published eight books let me
just mention a couple that are
noteworthy in this context venona
decoding soviet espionage in america
with Harvey Claire in 1999 the Soviet
world of American communism again with
Harvey Claire and this end Kyle Anderson
1998 and the secret world of American
communism co-authored with Harvey Claire
and Phil Rick fierce fierce of 1995 so
wonderful to have you John back here at
the center floors yours thank you very
much let me begin by making a few
comments on the book itself and then I
want to discuss its its place in the
literature one of the first things i
want to emphasize about the book is that
Professor Sibley has made energetic and
thorough use of a rich range of archival
sources that are available not only the
material that has become available in
recent years such as Venona and some of
material from soviet archives but
material that has been around from
earlier years but which has been because
of its sheer volume a difficult to
exploit well particularly FBI files that
have become available under the Freedom
of Information Act since the 1970s
congressional investigations which have
been around and available for many many
decades now but whom few people but
which a few people have actually taken
the trouble to go back and read many of
these hearings as well as some of the
results of various court actions her
footnotes and I do read footnotes these
are these are very rich and useful
footnotes which I think other historians
will be delighted to make use of to lead
them to material in 22 years this is a
highly detailed and richly documented
study and one that is very welcome let
me also say I wish this book had been
written 20 or 25 years ago not by
Professor Sibley that would been pushing
it a bit much but and of course the
whole book could not have been written
that long ago because of material that's
become recently available but much of
the story of this book perhaps half of
it perhaps a bit more could have been
written that long ago on the basis of
FBI files congressional investigations
and other material that was available
from the 1970s and into the 1980s but
that book was not written by someone at
that time and it is it does i think
point to one of the failures of the
historical profession in dealing with
this area that was of course not written
by me either my interest in the field of
espionage is a rather recent one and is
in fact an accident my chief interest as
a historian has been
in the domestic political history of the
American Communist Party and
anti-communism in its political and
labor aspects in the 1930s and 1940s I
did not really consider espionage to be
part of that story at all certainly i
had read the book by Alan Weinstein on
his case and by Ron ray dodged on the
Rosenberg case and some of the other
books that were around dealing with
Soviet espionage but I did not really
think that story those stories were
directly connected to my own interest in
the domestic history of the American
communist movement it was not until my
colleague Harvey Claire and I were
working in Comintern archives in Moscow
in 1992 and 93 that both he and I began
to realize that our assumptions that the
story of Soviet espionage and the story
of American communism were not as
separated as we thought in fact the
linkage was far closer than we had
imagined this first became clear to us
when we realized that we were reading
vetting messages from the KGB to the
Comintern asking for background
information on a series of American
communists who were later involved in
Soviet espionage and we when we came
across material from Earl broader the
head of the American party to the
Comintern and to the KGB regarding his
own assistance to Soviet espionage
efforts that led in indirectly for us to
develop an interest in the venona
decryption
after they became open and to our
writing our book venona one of the
things which I quickly discovered as
professor Claire and I tried to bring
ourselves up to speed on on the history
of Soviet espionage was that there was a
lack of any kind of a broad detail
scholarly level study of what was
already known or could be known about
Soviet espionage based on FBI files and
other sources as we began to look at FBI
files which have been open for decades
by dealing with some of the people we
ran across in winona we realized there
was a great deal here that had been
there but no one had looked and there in
fact was a consensus among historians
all through the 1970s and 80s into the
early 90s that there had not really been
very much Soviet espionage and certainly
emphatically it was not connected to the
American Communist Party at all well
both assumptions were wrong and both
assumptions also should not have existed
in the first place once we started
looking at material which was already
available it has certainly no criticism
of Professor Sibley to say that this
book should have been written 20 or 25
years ago at least large part of it at
last we have the book it is richly
documented it is i think a book which
will guide a great many other historians
as they try to to look into aspects of
the story to fill in details to fill in
gaps to pursue things which are not
clear from the existing evidence and
existing record it is a book at which I
think any historian interested in this
area will have to have on their shelf
and will consult constantly now in terms
of of a few matters of
on the book itself there's one one of
the themes which professor Sibley
discusses in there where I think she
tends to go back and forth on the matter
which I don't blame her because I tend
to go back and forth on the issue as
well which is the effectiveness of the
FBI in dealing with Soviet espionage in
the late 30s and 1940s there are times
in there where where as she tends to
write more positively about the about
the FBI's effectiveness and there are
other times when she refers to their
lethargy and the lack of effectiveness I
I to tend to be somewhat over
underwhelmed by the FBI is effectiveness
in this period there does seem to be a
major dependence on own defectors and
walk-ins to lead to major advances in
the area perhaps it's an inevitable
problem in the area i'm not sure but
certainly without gazette co and bentley
and chambers I think the FBI's record
would have been extremely limited now
one of the unknowns is that there may be
more to the story than we at present no
professor Sibley mentioned the KGB
officer yachts golf referring to the
what he perceived as a a very decided
tightening of FBI surveillance of their
activities in 1944 that forced them to
make a number of changes in their
operations that may be true or it may
have simply been his own paranoia but I
think the FBI record of this is not as
yet to my knowledge open I very much
wish the agency had a more forthcoming
attitude toward the release of the
records of this era I think it's it's
attitudes which may be based on insta
tional lab momentum and habit are
nonetheless from the point of view of
historian extremely frustrating to be
faced with heavily redacted material
from the 1930s no that is over 70 years
ago now one would think after 70 years
that there really is nothing worth
redacting anymore in fact I'm fairly
certain it's not worth redacting and I
think it is it is not a rational policy
on the part of the agency to continue to
withhold many of these investigative
reports of that early era withholding
material for 20 30 years that doesn't
really bother me it isn't really history
yet for a variety of reasons but the
material that is 50 60 and 70 years old
I think it is it is it is an irrational
policy with that i think i will i will
stop thanks you very much dr. Haynes
we're now
floor is open for your questions and
comments let me have her say I know
there's some of the most renowned
experts intelligence experts in the room
but we are not all intelligence experts
and so for those of us here who are not
familiar with all of the acronyms and
technical terms as well as those in the
viewing audience out there please
explain if you should use technical
terms or or acronyms as you pose your
question or comment area floor stockman
please identify yourself yes my name is
Stephen Shore could you take the
microphone
my name is Stephen sure i'm not in the
field of Intelligencer will not use any
acronyms that need to be clarified my
basic question is this that the
Communist Party in the united states
with slavish in its adherence to Soviet
policy and that it would serve as the
locus of espionage to me is hardly
surprising but how concentric were the
circles were in other words were that
with the circles of espionage for the
Soviets and the circle of Communist
Party membership essentially the same or
were there any individuals whose value
to the Soviet Union was heightened by
their not being members of the Communist
Party thank you um I think John probably
sport an expert on this and i am but i
would i would say speaking the consent
rissa tea some of the work that's been
done on Earl browser for instances made
dep who was course the head of the
communist party during this period in
the united states he was aware of
espionage and espionage practices and so
there was certainly a close link between
the top of the party just and there are
many other examples like that there were
also of course other activists in the
party who I don't know if you exactly
asked us who probably had no clue and
just to kind of confirm that many of
Bentley sources I did not know they were
giving information to the Soviet Union
you may be aware this they thought they
were giving it to the party only and so
they didn't feel you know they were
doing something culpably treasonous if
that would be the right word to use but
yeah I think this or the circles were
concentric but of course they were also
not necessarily always the same yeah let
me make a couple of comments about that
I think it's important to remember that
even though we now know at least at
least now I know that the party's
involvement in espionage was far closer
than then I had understood until the
1990s and in fact the party as an
institution participated in Soviet
espionage and acted as a auxiliary to
Soviet espionage nonetheless the party
was not an espionage agency the American
armies parties
primary purpose and its primary
activities were political organization
and that was where it voted most of its
resources most of its manpower and most
of it's money espionage was a lesser
activity of the party as an institution
so and also keep in mind that espionage
is not a mass movement by its very
nature the Soviet Union did not need and
to certainly did not want the depending
upon the arrow you're talking about the
40 50 to 60,000 members of the Communist
Party as spies I mean you don't run spy
agencies that way you don't need all
these people but the the average member
of the party was not a spy and did not
take place in party and spying
activities but the party as an
institution directly knowingly and
intentionally assisted Soviet espionage
the party assigned senior trusted
officials as liaison with Soviet
intelligence agencies perform such task
as as the agency's asked them to do
particularly the task performed by the
parties included you know when the
espionage agencies were considering the
recruiting of someone as a source they
would use the Communist Party often as a
vetting agency to gather background
material as to whether this person could
be trusted or not the party also
provided safe houses for meetings
between Soviet officers and their
sources the party also provided when
needed couriers I to carry material
between sources and the Soviet officers
and it did a variety of other actions
for Soviet espionage agency that really
greatly magnified the effectiveness of
Soviet intelligence just contrast that
with let's say an American agents
operating in the Soviet Union none of
these task
could be performed by some Russian
auxiliary for us everything had be done
by the professional officer if it was
done at all here in the United States
the effectiveness of Soviet espionage
was magnified many times by the
availability of the of the American
party to act as a auxiliary but let me
just add also had one addition to that
that was also a double-edged sword for
Soviet espionage they could only do that
as long as the US government and
American intelligence
counterintelligence agencies weren't
really conscious of it once attention
turned to the American party at the end
of World War two and once the political
and institutional environment the early
Cold War came the ability to use the
American party as auxiliary went from a
huge plus to a horrible disadvantage
because the American Communist Party was
not an espionage agency it was open to
infiltration its members were not
trained officers and the the whole
successful not the whole many of the
successful apparatuses the Soviets built
up in the 30s and early 40s blew up in
their face in 1945 in 1946 for the same
reason that had allowed them success
earlier it became a liability after that
point thank you John I wonder if I may
use the prerogative of the charea for a
moment if you could talk for a moment a
bit about the venona decrypt since those
have been mentioned here a number of
times and not everybody in the audience
might be familiar with this source and
perhaps some of the revelations that
have lately come from this type of
material well but on a is a is a cover
name given by the National Security
Agency for a code-breaking project
different doesn't mean anything and in
particular in fact the project had
different names earlier venona was the
last one I it was certainly one of the
most successful cryptographic projects
of American code breakers in the early
Cold War it began during the during the
war as an attempt to break into Soviet
diplomatic cable traffic to see if the
Soviets were possibly considering a
second nazi-soviet pact that would leave
the British and the Americans holding
the bag as we fought the Germans by the
time they broke into any of the traffic
it was 1946 the war was over in the
original rationale for the project had
disappeared but they also found when
they did break into some of the traffic
that they weren't breaking into
diplomatic traffic they were breaking
into Soviet espionage traffic the
Soviets sent tens hundreds of thousands
of cables between Moscow and Washington
and New York during World War two and in
wartime all international cables were
copies were kept by the US government
not just the Soviets but you know any
international cables the little war all
the Soviets do that of course but they
didn't really care because they were
using an unbreakable code so they didn't
care if we got copies of them what was
we could spin our wheels looking at
their unbreakable cables and that was
that was just our problem but it turned
out and at the Soviets we're using an
unbreakable code if it was done right
but it turned out they had made a
procedural error with a small portion of
that traffic and that procedural error
was noticed by our cryptographic agency
and it was eventually broken and they
eventually decoded in whole or in part
often in part nearly 3,000 cables and
that's out of hundreds of thousands of
cables
worldwide but those included hundreds of
cables between the KGB station in New
York and Washington and Moscow regarding
intelligence activities during World War
two by the way this break really only
occurs during the war years I mean
there's there only one or two mess
because it was a break that was time
limited I want to go into details about
that but the venona the decoded messages
identify more than 300 Americans as
assisting Soviet intelligence during
World War two about half of those could
be identified in terms of their real
name the other half they're still only
cover names but when that is combined
with the information provided by
elizabeth bentley and by whittaker
chambers and certain other defectors
along with the FBI's investigative file
it did give by the 1940s and 50s the
American government a understanding of
the wide sweep of Soviet espionage it
did not give them the ability to
prosecute these people for crimes but
there's always been a dilemma thing you
know that's inherent deluna i think in
counterintelligence it's not a criminal
justice enterprise it's not aimed at
sending spies to jail that's the kind of
icing on the cake it didn't do that it
has other purposes but the Venona
decryptions I think from a historians
point of view because they are actually
Soviet messages I mean you're reading
the Soviet mail it gives you a kind of
rock-hard basis for then judging the FBI
investigations judging bentley's at
credibility judging Whittaker Chambers
credibility and judging the credibility
of others who provide less certain a
testimony it's so it's a major
contribution I think to to figuring out
what is true and
not true in this area thank you yes
Jerry checked her in the back the
microphone hi I'm Steve Austin i would
say on the issue of the value of the
information that americans were working
for so v intelligence gave it's been
vastly underestimated and some examples
that I would give from the Rosenberg
group would be if you had to to pinpoint
the three most important technologies or
four most important technologies that
came out of the Second World War they'd
be the atomic bomb radar the proximity
fuse and a jet aircraft it's debatable
and there's been a lot of debate about
how much information about atomic
weapons the Rosenberg group gave but
Julius Rosenberg personally gave the
Soviets the proximity fuse now not only
blueprints of it but he actually gave
them a working proximity fuse the as far
as the radar goes Joel bar and saran
tales rant and some of the others in the
group gave details of every advanced
radar system that the United States was
making during the Second World War and
if you correlate that with CIA reports
about what the Soviets were producing in
the early 1950s the Soviets were
producing clones copies of certain
American radar systems and just by
coincidence there were exactly the ones
that bar and saran and the other ones
were working on the United States a
third technology that the Rosenberg
group so bell and sir anton bar gave the
Soviets was of analog computer systems
which were used for targeting for
anti-aircraft if you put all three of
those together you get what's the core
of the technology that's used even up
till two till the Iraq war analog
computers linked to search radar
proximity fuze that's what Saddam
Hussein used to try to defend Baghdad
more interestingly it's what the Soviets
used to shoot down the YouTube it was
the first time that they used a
proximity fuse so I could go on and more
about that but there are a lot of
important technologies that they gave
another thing to consider about that is
that you don't have to the Soviets
didn't have to use the information that
the Americans gave them to make copies
of something for it to be valuable the
Americans spent a tremendous amount of
money and attention and lives lost and
so on during the Cold War to try to find
out about Soviet defense technology not
because we wanted to copy it but because
we wanted to know what it was so we
could defend against it and so on so
again that for that reason stuff that
would that even if the Soviets didn't
use it didn't put it into production was
tremendously important to them and then
and then a final point I would make that
I think is is extremely interesting to
me and I don't think anybody's written
much about it is the fact that the
arrogance the naivety of the Americans
who were spying for the Soviet Union
during the Second World War in giving
technology they had no way of knowing
that the information that they were
giving to the Russians wouldn't get to
the Germans the they were giving
information to the Russians at a time
when Russian territory Soviet territory
was being overrun by by Germans and it
could have been quite conceivable that
some information that they gave would
have been given to the Germans if that
had happened in the case of the
proximity fuse or radar it could have
actually affected is certainly what it
would have caused a lot of Allied lives
and it could have affected the outcomes
of the war even and in fact if you want
to take it another step further they had
no way of verifying even that those were
Russians that they were dealing with it
all and it could have been what they
call false flag operation it could have
been because certainly American
intelligence hasn't hesitated and the
Brits and other people to to use false
flag operation as a way of getting
information from other people so to me
that just highlights the tremendous
arrogance and naivety of these people
thank you
we're we're just about out of time so
maybe we'll take one or two more
questions and then I'll give Katy and
John one final opportunity to respond
are there any more questions or yes very
briefly no place yet I can talk for
hours on this side and please the
previous speaker is looking at specifics
of how they Soviets benefited from
American technology a huge amount of
information all that there's a huge
amount of information on the specifics
including the nuclear field for example
in 1996 at dubna in Russia the Ministry
of atomic energy held the first meeting
of their Manhattan Project scientists it
was about 200 250 people many of the
speakers proudly boasted of how they use
the American information you're probably
aware that Guzan co past samples of
uranium-233 to the Soviets well two of
the speakers got up smiled said we
received them and we got some very
intersting measurements and they
presented the measurements at don't know
on a grander scale the first Soviet
atomic bomb RDS one was exactly a copy
of our Nagasaki bomb down to the last
screw and bolt
and they got much of that information
from a memorandum which is classified in
the Schechter's book number 12 or 13 on
the basis that American readers should
not be told that I suppose but they use
that to great advantage and there are
many other examples I can quote outside
of the dubna experience the problem with
evaluating Soviet espionage rest that
it's in always in the context of whether
someone was a communist or not and all
that sort of thing the actual effects of
their espionage has not been
investigated the information is there
and if it were investigated that would
point to additional sources of American
espionage thank you could you identify
yourself our own range I'm Jen final
speaker over here right here Alan horn
blonde Temple University Philadelphia
I'd be interested Kathy and your opinion
and John's as well it would seem that
the Soviet agents and couriers were
disproportionately Jewish very briefly
since we don't have a lot of time what
is the attraction for the Jews in the
30s and 40s to help the Soviet Union and
put their lives at risk well I think
Harry gold probably put it best and you
you probably know this because you're
doing a book on him he felt that the
Soviet Union offered some hope to
American Jews he thought that Stalin you
know little did he know I guess what was
going to happen to Jewish doctors and
was happening already too many Jews in
Russia offered some hope he himself had
seen his own father persecuted that
harassed at the factory he worked in
poor old Harry walking up what was it
the neighborhood we lived in the the
Nekor is attacked him the the local boys
attacked it because he was Jewish i mean
he he grew up with this and in the 1930s
as many jews did in this country and so
the Soviet Union seemed to offer some
kind of hope and particularly in this
period I mean he here as a man who
during the war he was 4f Harry gold it
was a spy in the 30s through the 40
showing worked also with the atomic
project and he was hanging out in this
some you know train station and somebody
attacked him is a [ __ ] bastard because
he you know wasn't done in uniform or
something and so all he could do was
think about you know his cause the
Soviet Union this gave him some dignity
and some hope and I'm not saying that
you know all Jews would've thought that
way god forbid but certainly I think for
many there was a sense of the Soviet
Union offered them a more hospitable
place even though this probably was a
rather distorted view of their for their
own futures and their families and they
might get here now that's only Harry
gold of course there are many many other
examples but I think he speaks
particularly eloquently to this issue
thank you John oh the only thing I'd add
is is the ethnic attraction of the party
the various groups of various times
change to their in the early 1920s the
largest ethnic group in the American
Communist Party were offense that ended
by the 1920s and was replaced by the
largest group being Jews in the in the
early 1930s there's also an aspect of
speed of assimilation with it there's an
impression on my part I'm not quite sure
exactly it's not an area that I really
pay that much attention to many of the
Jewish Americans were attracted to the
party were innocent frustrated
assimilationist they they were not
getting fully integrated into American
society as much as those who reject to
the party and of course keep in mind the
majority of American Jews were conscious
communism was always a minority taste
among every ethnic group if you want to
look at percentages of ethnic groups it
was the fence were the most radical
group in American history not the Jew
that's not on that thank you very much
well then let me in conclusion remind
you again that we'd love to see you here
on the 24th for Frank Gavin's talk and
invite you now outside to a small
reception but not before we give our
speakers a hand for some wonderful
Thank You Kathryn Sibley chairs the
history department at st. Joseph's
University red spies in America stolen
secrets at the dawn of the Cold War is
published by University Press of Kansas
on the web at Kansas press k u dot edu
in the summer of nineteen thirty-two at
the height of